the state of Maine has one of this
country's least severe coronavirus
outbreaks so far a total of only 53
people have died as of Tuesday a quarter
of the state's Health Department there
were a grand total of 33 people in the
state in hospitals with corona virus
that's out of a population of 1.3
million people and according to new
information flowing in from scientists
around the world we can be confident the
state will not collapse if it does open
back up and that would be a pretty good
idea at this point since one in every
seven people in the state of Maine is
now unemployed that's all thanks to
Governor Janet Mills who doesn't care at
all she's just ordered the state to
remain closed indefinitely Rick Savage
has had enough of this he owns a
restaurant in Bethel Maine
he says he's opening up tomorrow and
he's daring the state to stop him Rick
Savage joins us tonight Rick good to
have you on so I should just say at the
outset that during the course of this
last couple of months you gave away over
10,000 meals to people in your community
for free so it's not like you're not
engaged with the people around you you
are you're planning to open up tomorrow
that's illegal in the state of Maine why
are you doing it what do you think will
happen well the order originally started
it was May 1st so we were gearing up for
that we did what we were supposed to do
we closed for six weeks we cooked for
the community we went right through a
whole restaurant remodel that cleaned it
and it's time to open back up we've gone
throughout other parts of Maine people
are everywhere I've got a restaurant
that seats 250 people inside a deck that
seats 100 a 2,200 square foot patio so I
could put people at 6-foot space in
everywhere and get open back up for
business so if each person does that in
the state of Maine and tailors their
business for what works and people feel
comfortable coming in come in if they
don't feel comfortable call us and we'll
deliver to your car if you want to go
sit on a deck sit on the deck you know
we've tried to call the governor
you can't even get a hold of them the
lawmakers are left in a dock both
Republicans and Democrats she's doing
this all rogue on her own so we've had
enough of it we're encouraging all
businesses in Maine to open up we should
have never been
shut down in the first place we need to
open back up get this summer tourist
business going we're gonna lose a third
of our restaurants who knows how many
motels and other businesses so we're
advocating for everybody not just for my
restaurant it's time to go back to work
if people don't want to go out
quarantine yourself we're a very clean
restaurant I got one of the cleanest
restaurants in the state of Maine and
I'm gonna challenge the state to come
and see you know hey this is what we're
doing if you don't like it take me to
court
and then if they do take me to court
I'll save my tax money that I collect
this month and I'll use that to fund a
lawyer so last time I checked you're in
Oxford County Oxford County Maine I
don't think there are any coronavirus
deaths in Oxford County Maine it's a
state really comprised of small
businesses which are dying as you just
pointed out so I understand why you're
doing this what do you think the
authorities Janet Mills will do I mean
you're you're admitting this on
television what do you think is gonna
happen tomorrow I don't think anything's
gonna happen because she's over her head
she's not consulting the experts she's
just doing this to break aa state even
more than we are right now we're broke
we were broke before this she spent our
rainy day fund two months into being in
office so she's trying to get federal
money from this from the government to
bail her out so she makes the state look
like we're broke she's going to get more
federal money and she doesn't care about
the people in the state of Maine if she
did she'd be reaching out to these
businesses I told them it when this
first happened I said if I called the
lawmakers I said if you guys gave us
back the tax money that we collected for
you the eight percent for
january/february and you suspend March
we could all get through this and it
would be really easy for you guys to do
you know the restaurants that are open
the mean the summer business is not even
here they're not even open so it's been
really easy they already had those
numbers we sent them the money never
heard back from him matter of fact I got
a letter a couple weeks ago that said
don't forget you still owe marches sales
tax ah come on Janet Mills is the most
incompetent dictatorial self-involved
governor I have seen in a long time
you know Godspeed Rick Savage good luck
tomorrow truly I hope you'll tell us how
the clay I just really appreciate Tucker
coming on and I hope all these
restaurants will be able to open